Alhamdulillah.
My respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters, I welcome all of you with
the Islamic greetings.
[Applause]
May peace, mercy and blessings of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala be on all of you. I
would request the ladies on my right
please, please will you keep silent? The
ladies, can you keep silent please?
We're going to start. The program has
started.
It's a pleasure and honor for
me to be present on the second
day and the topic of my talk today is
religion in the right
perspective. Religion according to the
Oxford dictionary means a belief in a
superhuman controlling power a personal
god or gods that deserve worship and
obedience.
In short, religion means belief and
worshiping
God. So if you want to understand any
religion, the best way is to first
understand the concept of God in that
religion.
It is not appropriate to try and
understand a religion or try to
understand the concept of God in any
religion by observing the followers of
that religion because many a times the
followers themselves are not aware about
their own religion or their own
scriptures. So the best and the most
authentic way of understanding any
religion or understanding the concept of
God in a religion is to read the
authentic scriptures of that
religion. So today we'll understand
different religions in the right
perspective by understanding what the
scriptures of the religion have to speak
about their god.
I start my talk by quoting a verse from
the gur Quran from surah aliman chapter
number three verse number 64 where
Allahh
says say oh people of the
book come to common terms as us and you
which is the first term
Allahill that we worship none but
Allah that we associate no partners with
him
that we erect not among ourselves lords
and pages other than Allah. If then they
turn back say
witness that we are Muslims bowing our
will to Allah subhana wa t'ala this
verse of the glorious Quran is the
master key for
dawa. It
says see people of the book though it
refers to the Jews and Christians
specifically but this verse can be used
to speak
about people of any religion.
It
says come to common terms as been us and
you which is the first term Allahill
Allah that we worship none but Allah.
One thing common alhamdulillah in all
the religions is that the followers of
any religion they believe that almighty
God which they worship they believe is
the same God for themselves and for
others. The God which the Hindus worship
they believe is the same God for the
Hindus as well as the non-Hindus. The
God which the Christian worship they
believe is the same God for the
Christians and the non-Christians.
Similarly, the God which the Muslims
worship, Allah subhanana wa ta'ala, we
believe is the same God for the Muslims
and the non-Muslims.